let's get started let me welcome you to
what is the third philosophy pop-up i do
uh two of these a month uh one on
youtube live and one uh on facebook live
and very different uh processes for both
of those
one off of my facebook page one off on
my youtube profile and i'm kind of
experimenting right now with seeing
which format works better for for what
we're trying to do so um today
i thought since you know we're building
up to october which is a huge month for
all things stoic related because we have
stoic week stoicon there are stoicon x's
and also we had some really cool uh news
if you haven't looked at stoicism today
yet today
modern stoicism has finally
entered into a new phase of its
development as an organization
so um i thought that this month what i
would do is is talk about
stoicism
uh since since it's something that i'm
i'm kind of you know in the mix with and
i wanted to focus specifically on the
issue of
what does in accordance with nature mean
because that trips up a lot of people so
i'll talk a little bit about that at the
beginning
but um anything is fair game we can talk
about anything stoicism related we can
talk about uh anything in terms of other
philosophical stuff i can see all of
your your
comments and um
uh you know sign-ins uh people are
saying uh you know i'm from here i'm
from there
and uh questions i'll i'll answer them
as time goes on
so let me start out by talking first a
little bit about
you know i mentioned modern stoicism um
and actually i'll also answer a question
sort of
before it gets so buried in the stream
uh somebody write a cod mon zohar 2 is
neo-stoicism a word it is indeed a word
and it's an old-fashioned word um
when we use the term neo-stoicism that
actually refers to historical phenomena
within uh from the the renaissance on
through the early modern period
there were people who call themselves
neo-stoics and so
for people who are doing you know modern
adaptations of stoicism in the
contemporary world
we tend to use the term
modern stoics rather than neo-stoics
so it's not the same thing as like
neo-aristotelians where
neo-aristotelians mean contemporary
aristotelians in many respects
and there is actually a division within
the the current stoic
large community
uh between people who view themselves as
more traditional stoics sometimes they
call themselves orthodox stoics and then
people who
um are you know from a wide range of
viewpoints adapting it in certain ways
and leaving some things out and that
will have something to do with with some
of the topic that we're talking about
here some proponents of modern stoicism
think that we can dispense with this
whole you know living in accordance with
nature
bit so let me talk about about that
first
um
one of the key ideas early on in the
development of stoicism
is this living in accordance with nature
or being in accordance with nature
and nature in in greek is phusis
and that it doesn't mean exactly the
same thing as what we tend to think of
when when you know people are talking
about the natural sciences it
encompasses that but it in a certain way
it goes beyond that so um you know the
natural philosopher
uh would would also be studying say
psychology as we see aristotle doing in
his his nico mccain ethics or things
like that
the stoics talked about living in
accordance with nature and early on
i imagine we don't actually have any
records of this but people were you know
askings you know what the hell do you
mean by that you know so this is
something that they actually clarified
and if you want to see
um some of the texts where where we have
some some summaries of this you want to
look in a few different sources one is
diogenes laertes lives of the
philosophers book seven which is about
the stoics and it talks about zeno and
and what he did and their doctrines and
then it talks about their successors
you also want to check out cicero
specifically i would say if you only
could pick a few books his on duties
uh the
on the ends and then the tuscaloon
disputations because there's a lot of
discussions about stoicism and nature in
that and then we're going to see it pop
up in in various places in the the
stoics who we still actually have texts
of like
musonius rufus is going to talk about it
seneca will reference it
epictetus will reference it and he'll do
a kind of interesting twist that i'll
talk about and then marcus aurelius and
even uh you know later authors will
reference it i actually checked out
yesterday uh so i could re-read it arius
didymus is epitome of stoic ethics
there's a lot of discussion of what uh
being in accordance with nature means
for that
so um one thing that i think is really
helpful from the beginning
is to sort of
put on hold or or bracket
um modern conceptions of what nature is
because if we want to understand what
these you know
uh
you know third century uh on thinkers
are are talking about we want to
understand
we want to understand it in terms of
what what their texts actually say
and we don't want to read in a lot of
other stuff this is where where a lot of
criticisms of the stoics tend to be off
base because the stoics may mean
something different by nature than what
somebody else does for example in that
famous nietzsche passage that so many
people love to post on the modern
stoicism group as if they're you know
announcing something new nietzsche has a
very very different conception of nature
than the stoics did and so he's
criticizing them for not essentially not
sharing the same viewpoint on it
as he has
the stoics distinguished between nature
understood as the totality of everything
that is so being in accordance with
nature
involves our relation to the universe
which we can understand in part uh
through
uh the sciences right it's very helpful
for that
um but it also has to do with the kind
the nature of the kind of beings that we
are a distinctively human nature
and for the stoics i'm actually going to
concentrate on that part first and then
i'll come back to
uh the the other part and then um
you know maybe start taking some of the
questions that i see piling up um
cicero is a great example of this so
cicero in you're going to see this in on
duties and on the ends
when he's having us you know he's
presenting the stoic position
and cicero by the way is not himself a
hardcore stoic he's an eclectic he he uh
likes some elements of their ideas and
he he actually identifies more closely
with the academic skeptic school
although he's not totally on on track
with them either
cicero will talk about how the stoics
thought that
all living beings attempt to continue
their being
and they do what conduces to to their
life
human beings are like that as well we
have these drives for self-preservation
for doing things that that are going to
conduce to to
our our life but we also
uh are rational and rationality is not
just a matter of say possessing logic or
being able to
uh do science or or things like that
it's much more basic it has to do with
our capacity to to think uh in a variety
of flexible ways
in many situations and the stoics
thought that rationality the more that
we develop it the more that we're
actually because it's not something we
can take for granted it doesn't just
automatically develop the way you know
uh with proper cultivation uh the the
seed turns into a corn plant and then
produces more corn or something like
that
um it requires education it requires
cultivation there's a lot of ways in
which rationality can be damaged or or
go astray but when it is properly
developed
we
realize
that our good
isn't just our good that it lies in
how we're related to other people
and we understand ourselves as social
creatures as part of a larger whole that
could be very small like a family and
you know our immediate relationships or
it could be much larger uh like humanity
as such so the stoics you know are
ultimately going to be these
cosmopolitans who who think that you
know everybody in some sense matters
even if everybody is screwed up
as the stoics think most people in fact
are including themselves on the way to
becoming less screwed up right
so we have this this common human nature
and
to live in accordance with nature then
means not just to do whatever you feel
like doing or what feels natural because
maybe your maybe your human nature is
kind of screwed up maybe you've got bad
habits maybe culture has been teaching
the wrong sorts of things you've drawn
the wrong sorts of lessons it's actually
to to get closer and closer to this
ideal of the virtuous person the person
who actually has and has fully developed
these virtues of
cicero talks about this as well
part of what it means to be a rational
being is we want to understand things
we want to make sense of things um
we also have to live together in in you
know relationships and in society
and that's where justice comes in and
justice for the stoics doesn't just mean
a strict kind of legalistic justice it
extends even to what we nowadays would
call benevolence um treating other
people well or kindness or generosity
and again if you want to see discussions
of this read cicero's on duties it's
right there in book one
wonderful text i'm actually teaching it
in my
two ethics sections for marquette this
semester
and i'm hoping the students will enjoy
it as much as as i know i do
um
they're one of the virtues and courage
isn't just you know being a tough guy or
resisting fear it's resisting fear for
the right reason at the right time
standing up for what's right and then of
course temperance the moderation of our
our appetites for for things um
self-control in a way
these are the things that comprise a
fully developed human nature and so
living in accordance with nature
doesn't mean just you know following our
you might say baser instincts or doing
what it is that the evolutionary
biologists tell us we're all about you
know uh the stoics that say that's a
um
degenerate or
or um selective understanding of human
nature this other part is possible for
us as well
now you know who do we point to as
examples of this um you know there are
some examples uh and and it's
interesting this is a bit of a
digression um and i won't do too many of
these because i don't want to take up
too much time with digressions but
um
so you know
there's this big question well who is
the virtuous person who has virtue
developed to the highest extent
cicero if you read his works
discussing these sorts of issues
particularly about virtue he says you
know
we can set the bar very high but if if
we want it to be more practical for us
we've got to look at people who have
some of the virtues but maybe not all of
them or they've developed them to a
certain extent but not not fully and
here he differs from the stoics because
some of the stoix saw virtue is kind of
like an off on switch some of the time
right either you got it or you don't um
and some went so far as to say look
either you're virtuous or you're vicious
which means uh most of us are vicious
right cicero said no no we can look at
some great examples i need to cite
examples from roman history um which we
can't relate to that easily unless we we
know the history but he he also brought
up a lot of other uh sort of you know
examples that we we could relate to
because we can see the principles behind
it this person behaved this way um
and so that is part of what it means to
live in accordance with nature now
there's there's entailments to that
which would include um you know
cultivating our persons right doing the
sort of instrumental things we need to
do
in order to be able to live in
accordance with nature so there are some
things that by themselves aren't in
accordance with nature or out of
accordance with nature but our use of
them can can make them so think about
wealth for example you know the stoics
don't say that you shouldn't have any
wealth they're not cynics who who sort
of rejected
all external goods um
at least you know from what we can tell
as being valueless compared to virtue
the stoics said you know
[Music]
sometimes wealth can be used to to you
know promote good ends um it's not it's
not automatically going to do that but
you can use wealth in accordance with
nature you can raise your children in a
way that's in accordance with nature
which means you can also do it in a way
that's that's out of accordance with
nature
um now going back to the sort of like
let's call it capital n nature not just
human nature but but um you know the
whole universe
the stoics also think that we ought to
try to
uh you know adapt ourselves as best as
we can to the way things go so there's
certain things that are not possible for
us human beings at least at this point
given the current level of technology
and um
you know those are the sort of things
that we just have to sort of live with
and and accept and not get all worked up
about uh because that's gonna then
affect our living in accordance with
nature in terms of our own human nature
and so you'll see a lot of discussion
about you know
being okay with with the circumstances
understanding things that are physical
processes as physical processes the wind
is not out there blowing in your face
because it wants to you know screw you
over or tick you off or something like
that uh i mean people do have a lot of
you know sort of crazy notions about
these these sorts of things
and so you know um
studying uh human nature
and the nature of the universe can be
very useful the stoics did have some
some views on that um this is what we
what we call the stoic physics right
and i mentioned the distinction between
traditional stoics and
and modern stoics
modern stoics tend to um
you know
be very adaptable when it comes to
accepting things from the traditional
stoic physics
for example the notion that the universe
itself is a rational being
uh and and cares about us um many of the
modern stoics reject that that point of
view right traditional stoics would say
that that's an intrinsic part of it um
the one other thing i do want to mention
before i start looking at all these
these uh questions that i see
coming up in the live chat
um
epictetus i mentioned that he does
something a little bit different so if
you read epictetus much you're going to
see him
referring to something that we translate
typically as moral purpose in english
or as
faculty of choice or some some people
will translate it as will or volition
and this in greek is pro-irasis
it's a term that that epictetus gives a
particularly heavy weight to
the only other person in the ancient
period who gives it a similarly
important place in their moral theory is
actually aristotle but it's not
precisely the same thing for epictetus
as it is for aristotle it's more limited
for aristotle
for epictetus the faculty of choice
is um
it's it's sort of in the ruling faculty
the way in which we we actually do
decide things and it's not something
radically different from the rational
faculty this is an interesting uh you
know
part of of stoic uh psychology you might
call it now what's the import for this
epictetus is not just going to talk
about living in accordance with nature
or about living and you know living a
virtuous life or something like that
is going to talk about
having or maintaining our pro-iracis our
faculty of choice in accordance with
nature
so this is a bit of a wrinkle
because you can say well what does that
actually mean and then you know they
they give lots and lots of examples so
uh i'll just give you one example um
your family members are kind of jerks
and um they they you know say
mean things to you even though you're
you're trying to be good to them
um you have a choice
you can keep your faculty of choice in
accordance with nature which would mean
to treat them as human beings it doesn't
necessarily mean to take any sort of
abuse they're going to dish out there
there's points at which justice would
would you know say no i shouldn't put up
with that sort of thing
but you can avoid getting angry at them
every every time that you get angry uh
not only epictetus but but also cicero
say uh you're you're out of accord with
nature um even though we might say oh
that's just human nature no that's
that's that's a kind of damaged human
nature that's not a realized human
nature and so we have the capacity to
choose about the ways in which we choose
to reform our habits to even identify
our habits and to think about this sort
of stuff
that's what epictetus is calling our
attention to
all right so now i see there's a ton of
uh questions so i'm going to scroll up
and get past the hello everybody i'm
from here and from there
stuff um so here's a here's a good uh
question
uh coming from silver silver shadow x i
am skeptical of philosophy as a form of
therapy since you do philosophical
counseling what has been your experience
how did you get started
um well so um
i got started i would say
in researching anger because i
um
that's something i've struggled with
pretty much my whole life
um and i've gotten somewhat better with
it and a good bit of the getting better
took place through seeing what ancient
philosophers um had to say about it
which which often is so good that it can
go toe-to-toe with uh contemporary
psychological stuff
um
it was a really pressing problem for
them and then i started you know looking
into other things and and so i've been
very interested in human motivation and
how we work upon ourself in in what a
lot of people these days like to call
philosophy as a way of life i'm i'm not
so so uh you know enthused about about
that title because i think that if we
look at actual you know philosophical
stuff that's not a new idea that that
you know uh
pirados somehow just popped into the
middle of the 20th century lots of 20th
century philosophers treated philosophy
as a way of life um but i i found that
it was it was helpful for me um
and i saw that there were resources in a
lot of uh
great thinkers that that could be
adapted and that what was going on quite
often in the better psychotherapeutic
theories
was often replicating
what was what was going on or could be
improved by bringing it into
into there and then you know it's not
just about dealing with say emotional
issues or stuff like that some of the
psychological counseling i do is with uh
startup ceos
who are trying to you know get better at
you know practical reasoning thinking
out you know relations between means and
ends how to prioritize
all all of that sort of stuff
um
that's uh
you know should you be skeptical of
philosophy as a form of therapy
you should be skeptical of a couple
things one is somebody just putting a
book in your hand whether it's a book a
philosophy or a self-help book or a you
know one of these uh
psychotherapeutic workbooks or something
like that and saying go to it
because that's probably not going to be
all that helpful you generally you need
somebody else you know to
to talk with and to work your way
through things with
and i think there's there's people out
there who um are not particularly
well suited to to doing that that that
try their hand at it um
uh so you know
you know you gotta kind of figure out
who who's good and who's not but my my
experience has been that resources from
classical
and even some you know later you know
medieval and early modern and
contemporary philosophy can be
incredibly
useful and i i do one of my big
consulting projects is actually working
with a uh
a center a psychotherapy center in
helping them turn
philosophical cons philosophical
concepts into psychotherapeutic
constructs so so i see there's there's a
lot of of use to it stoicism turns out
to be particularly uh helpful for that
here's another really good question
gum nom 1000 i'm recently going through
religious turmoil can stoicism fill up
the gap of religious belief or devotion
um so it really depends uh
you know um
it depends on what your religious belief
or devotion was like um
you know it's not just stoicism but all
sorts of things can come to be kind of a
substitute for
for uh
a belief system that one
felt very strongly about that had some
practical
implications that's why we sometimes see
people jump from system to system
i don't know that i would actually
pick up stoicism
to be a substitute in that way myself
although i think there are some people
who do that um
you know and they sort of go
whole heart hog wild into it they become
very enthusiastic
um but then i don't know that all that
many of them actually stick with it
stoicism is
really about you know developing
self-awareness
understanding your relationship with the
world and others
understanding your own your own
background and why you do the things
that you do and making decisions about
what you want to change
and what you want to what good things
you have that you want to sort of
reinforce
[Music]
there aren't religious rituals or things
like that
in
most people's interpretations of
stoicism
and there are actually christian stoics
who don't accept you know say for
example all of the stoic physics but
do in fact you know
connect up um stoicism with with uh
their christian practice uh i know some
secular buddhists who who connected up
as well so
um
[Music]
all right
so
here's another question astro 333
wouldn't the philosophies of nietzsche
and certain kamu be a form of modern
stoicism
they take a lot of ideas from them
well so taking ideas from somebody
doesn't mean that you're actually
in that tradition
nietzsche is very critical about the
stoics quite honestly
and i mentioned that that one
passage that everybody likes to quote
you know every so often just just go on
to the modern stoicism uh facebook group
and about once a week somebody will put
that up there and say hey nitra said
this doesn't that mean all the stoics
are raw you know um
nietzsche and sartan camus and many
other uh
19th 20th century philosophers you know
they they read about stoicism and
they talk about many similar themes
but
i mean start right off the bat
you know stoicism thinks that there is a
human nature sart says nope that's
that's not the case so stoicism would be
sort of like those those other
philosophies that are saying there is a
human essence
and he's rejecting that
you know kamu believes that the universe
fundamentally is absurd and he's trying
to figure out how do we how do we deal
with that
stoics don't believe the universe is
absurd
so there's there's you know there's
interesting uh connections there are
some similar themes
there may even be some similar uh bits
of advice
i don't see anything in say nature or
sort of camus like what goes on with
stoic practice
um
but there might be some people out there
who've adapted nature or sardar kamu in
that way
um
ennis as as forest says can you tell us
about marcus aurelius yeah i'll keep
that one very brief um he's you know
he's a roman emperor one of the good
ones there weren't many and
he was a uh stoic um he
he uh studied philosophy um
he was uh uh stuck in what we would call
a you know a management position for a
very long time uh mo you know good
portion of the
second half of his life
and he tried to you know apply
his stoicism to
the problems of being an emperor
and then he wrote down these thoughts
that he has he's very influenced by
epictetus
um
and uh brings him up quite a bit
and that's you know
the the key thing is his meditations
there's also a nice correspondence with
with uh fronto that we learn a bit from
by the way i should put in a picture so
donald robertson has been doing a lot of
stuff recently on marcus aurelius
and you'll see him posting quite
frequently
uh some really interesting bits of
information in the stoicism group on
facebook
here's a really interesting question um
by christy hanganu
how can plato's and aristotle's works
have been kept but the stoics are
epicureans who came after have so few
works remaining
[Music]
well
that's a good question
you know when it comes down to it we do
in fact have a lot of plato's works
we don't have a lot of what aristotle
wrote
if we look at diogenes laertes
catalog of aristotle's works we're
missing a lot of them
and
one of the things that we're missing
that i would particularly have loved to
to have access to aristotle
we have one book by aristotle called the
athenian constitution and by
constitution he doesn't mean something
like a written document uh you know like
we have with our our constitution here
in the united states he means sort of a
a history of the political development
and the you know
social mores and and all of that
involved in a particular political
community
so aristotle and his students did over a
hundred of these of different greek
states and societies and we only have
one of them the athenian one
um
now um
the stoics we we do have a good bit of
stuff it's mostly the later stuff
we can reconstruct a good portion of
what the stoics were about
through cicero and
even even people who sometimes disagree
with them like plutarch and galen
the epicureans epicurus was one of the
most prolific writers in antiquity and
we have almost nothing from him
what we do have is preserved thankfully
because diogenes laertes was was nice
enough to write it all out and stick it
into his uh
lives of the philosophers because he was
really impressed by epicurus
um with the epicureans i mean we do also
have an epicurean literature later on
you know like lucretius and people like
that with the epicureans
um they tended to be
um viewed by most of the other
philosophical schools as
you know off-base and
in religious contexts epicurean
philosophy
was often just sort of a synonym for
atheism
you know you'll see the epicureans
referred to sometimes synonymously with
atheists so that might explain part of
it
um
[Music]
the stoics
you know why did we lose chrysippus why
did we lose xeno
why don't we have posidonius and
peniteus and all that
we don't really know
and every once in a while we're lucky
enough to find some new scrolls or
or uh you know bits of things here and
there
um
but for example there's there's actually
a cool thing from
from epic epicurus called the vatican
sayings that is because it was found in
the vatican library which is not a you
know super secret place you know there's
all these funny conspiracy theories that
go way back about oh they're hiding
things no it's just very disorganized
and uh
in a lot of cases you know manuscripts
may have uh you know included a lot of
different things and it takes scholars
going in and digging around to find
these
these uh these things
um i actually had a professor who who
was digging around in the vatican
library and and found uh in in one
manuscript uh a portion of it that
belonged to another guy and he
recognized it and you know wrote an
article about it
um
so you know why why don't we possess
more i i don't i don't really know i
will say this um some of the stuff that
we do have
uh was preserved by those medieval monks
um they they liked seneca uh
interestingly enough um
and uh they did preserve epictetus
although they inserted a bunch of you
know little little christianizing things
here and there so the text is not
actually uh cleaned up until until the
renaissance so
all right uh
let me scroll down a little bit
[Music]
i see a lot of sort of short
things that are hard to figure out what
they are as questions
um so if you do ask a question you
actually don't want to like like follow
make it make it something like a full
sentence or else i can't figure out what
it's saying
um
here we go
um
oops
scrolling uh
just lost where i was
here we go
um could i explain more about modern
versus traditional stoicism this is
alonso cervantes um
yeah it's it's uh
modern stoicism
um we just actually did an interesting
symposium on this in
stoicism today which is on the modern
stoicism site where we had um
[Music]
seven or eight of the members the the
steering committee members of the modern
stoicism organization weigh in with what
they think modern stoicism is and they
don't all completely agree with each
other
um john sellers wrote another one
and i'm going to put that together with
my my own uh reflections on it in
another follow-up piece uh maybe maybe
next week or the week after that
so modern stoicism is kind of a wide
spectrum right and i guess you could say
if there's one thing that connects all
of it together it's it's that it tries
to take classical stoicism
and adapt it selectively
uh and interpretively to to modern life
so
the things in the stoic physics that
that
you know we we just don't really
buy into like the notion that the the
universe is going to you know disappear
into a
conflagration the ekpirosis
uh and then start again
i don't you know i don't
think anybody really accepts that in the
modern stoic thing a lot of modern
stoics are actually atheists or they may
be religious believers belonging to you
know one of the major world religions
um
in part because the the the parts of
stoicism that that are tied in with the
traditional stoic conception of religion
which if you want to see reads cicero's
on the nature of the gods because it's
it's uh presented there
um they just don't buy that stuff you
know they don't they don't buy the
pantheism or the the universe is
one big sentient creature
um
you know i think the atheist ones
because they say well that
that's not that way and the other one is
because they say well that's you know
that's not uh the way they consid
they conceive of god right as just being
the universe
um traditional stoicism takes the um
the stoic physics at least certain
elements of it particularly in terms of
like providence and
and uh you know everything being ordered
providentially seriously there's
actually uh in traditional stoicism
uh you can become ordained as a stoic
philosopher
weddings and ceremonies and stuff like
that because you know we here in america
we uh you know all you have to do is say
that you're running some sort of
religious organization and you can
ordain people to do that
so
there's a lot of debate which i consider
very healthy about precisely what modern
stoicism is
i think personally that if it's not
really grounded in some way in the texts
um
that
we shouldn't really call it stoicism so
i'm i'm willing to set a kind of cut off
point and say that people who just
happen to mention the dichotomy of
control or put a picture of marcus
aurelius or epictetus in their blog post
or video
they're not really doing stoicism
they're doing something that we might
call stoicism light or
you know
in some cases just exploiting it
and there are a lot of people who who
take up stoicism
and then try to make it serve some some
other purposes um
you know
for example the modern stoics are cosm
the stoics were cosmopolitans and they
were firm believers in justice
so if if your interpretation of stoicism
is is this you know one that stresses
sort of hyper masculinity and virtue
says masculinity
and um
you know that you got to be as tough as
possible
that's not really stoicism that's that's
something that um
you know might might take the mantle of
stoicism but it's not really stoicism
because there's major parts of stoicism
that wind up contradicting it you know
you can't use stoicism for for example
ethnonationalism
because of the cosmopolitanism all
you've got to do is read cicero again
somebody was very proud of rome but who
recognized that there was a uh you know
wider wider range that we need to think
about or read epictetus and you'll see
that that's just not compatible so so
there's you know there's traditional
stoicism there's modern stoicism and
then there's this whole penumbra of
stuff that that sometimes people call
stoicism that really if if we read the
text and get to know them better we say
that well that's not really stoicism
um
i answered the question about nietzsche
so i'm going to skip over the the absurd
stuff
um
let's see here
oh here's a great
question from daniel
chev yakov i think is how
should be pronouncing it
does stoicism have anything to say in
particular about dealing with
confrontation or being courageous yeah
actually it does quite a bit
i would say that you're going to find
some good discussions of that in
again in cicero's texts like on duties
there's an entire section devoted to
courage
interestingly you'll also see some great
discussion in seneca's on anger
uh in part because
anger
you know
a lot of people conceive of anger as
something that's useful when we have to
deal with confrontations and seneca like
most of the stoics makes the case
that
it really isn't
uh that that that reliable of an ally to
drawn and that instead we should be
relying upon reason practical reasoning
and getting ourselves to do the right
thing there are times when when we do
have to stand up for ourselves epictetus
also talks about this these these sorts
of topics as well
so um yeah dealing dealing with with
confrontation one of the key things i
would say is we don't want to go and
confront people just for the sake of
confronting them right
courage for the stoics uh involves um
you know resisting our our fears and
standing fast in the face of adversity
for the right reasons
not just because we we want to do it
right epictetus actually talks about
you know people who like make up their
mind about something and then they they
stand firm and it's the wrong thing and
he says that's really dumb
that's not that's not being virtuous at
all that's just being obstinate so that
that's an important part
and then you know stoicism um can help
us deal with our our fears we can
examine them we can you know one of the
things that happens
when we feel afraid in confrontations
is we
we
worry about you know
all these other things that are going to
be spillover from it and we
we present those possibilities to us as
if they're probabilities
and we allow ourselves to feel more fear
or anxiety about that
[Music]
so you know stoicism can can help us
with that
um
[Music]
let's see here
oh here's here's a nice quote phil
atwood
the second is posting the best years of
your life are the ones in which you
decide your problems are your own you do
not blame them on your mother the
ecology or the president from alfred uh
yeah alfred ellis
um
uh yeah that's you know that's in line
with with uh stoicism
uh epictetus says that the the person
who's been
practicing stoicism uh moves from
blaming others
uh first to blaming himself and then
after a while doesn't blame anybody
christopher birch how would epictetus
advise us on dealing with everyday
frustrations and just plain coping with
circumstances beyond our control
well he gives us all sorts of advice
about that not just in the end caridian
but in his much longer discourses which
um
uh
the uh
the end careening is just sort of a best
hit slit list of
um you know one thing is is
here's one practical thing we can do
we can reframe
the everyday frustrations
that we're experiencing by um thinking
in terms of what's what what in them is
in our control what in them is not in
our control
and whether it really makes sense for us
to get
uh very upset about the things that
aren't in our control they're not going
to go into our control because we get
angry or afraid or ashamed
or
uh desirous about them
um
you know they're even less responsive
than people like you know when we go and
bother people because we're like hey
i've got this problem i need you to
solve it for me and they're like you
know imagine you're like at the dmv and
you want people to make a special case
for you right um they don't want to make
a special case for you at most dmvs
uh
and at least with a person you can
reason with them if you're worried about
like you know your coffee tasting bad or
something like that
you know go get yourself another coffee
or
or uh
be okay with not drinking coffee or
you know there's all sorts of other
possibilities um
let me take a look at this one
uh
almightyohm asks a
sort of big open-ended question do you
think this new modern malays will create
a new philosophical movement or school
born of neo-nationalism consumption
economy political plutocracy etc
so i'm imagining that those are part of
the the malaise right
that's being discussed
i mean there's new philosophical
movements in schools being created all
the time
it's kind of
an ongoing process that's why it's part
of why it's so hard for any one person
in the philosophy business
just to stay on top of um
you know what's going on in the 21st
century
you can't read everybody you can't
follow everybody there's always a lot
happening some of it is i think for the
sake of creating something novel
but some of it is is really trying to
respond to new exigencies
i'm sure so sure i'm sure there'll be
lots of new philosophical movements in
schools the question is whether they're
any good
whether they're really going to help us
or whether we should you know pay more
attention to
classical philosophy
here's another interesting question
from loath of bread that's a good pun
there
is stoicism pragmatic in your opinion
so that's that's interesting to ask me
because where i did my philosophical
formation
southern illinois university carbondale
is in fact one of the few places that
has a philosophy graduate program where
you can study classical american
philosophy including pragmatism
uh with with you know top-notch experts
on it
there's sort of a handful of places in
america where you can do that
um ironically american philosophy gets
less taught than the anglo-american
import analytic philosophy
or the continental philosophy
um
so when we talk about pragma pragmatic
we can talk about whether it's got
connections with pragmatism
understood through say purse james dewey
people like that
uh or whether we're just being you know
using it with a lowercase p being kind
of broad in our understanding of that
like saying that it's practical and the
answer to that is yes stoicism
is practical philosophy
one big branch of it is ethics and stoic
ethics
is precisely about how to you know
understand and transform your your life
because it's the one that you've got to
work on
and that involves you know again talking
about this understanding what is in
accordance with nature what's not in
accordance with it choosing the one
instead of the other
and we can we can go on and on with that
even the stoic logic which they made
some interesting contributions to
is also pragmatic
in the sense that you know it's it's
there to serve
living well
epictetus you'll see him talking about
this a great example one of the
discourses he's got somebody who's who's
in one of his classes
and you know what's one of the top
questions that students always bring up
when is this ever going to be useful for
me and and so epictetus taught logic as
well as ethics
and he's like yeah if you don't want to
study it
don't study it uh see what happens now
when you get into a situation where you
actually need to distinguish between a
good you know argumentative appeal and a
bad one or a good uh framework and a bad
one uh of you know
how we connect our thoughts together
you're kind of screwed because you
didn't want to study the logic and you
want to practice it but that's on you
buddy now now do you want to come back
to class and uh we'll go over it again
and you know epictetus is very pragmatic
that way
and he takes his cues from socrates um
socrates he says uh went around and you
know was was telling people you know
here's how i think you ought to
prioritize things the soul is more
important than the body you know pay
attention to the care of the self and
all that and and epictetus says you know
only one person in a thousand actually
listened to him
um
and
he kept on doing it
and epictetus is you know if somebody
reads his works and uh says well this is
all [ __ ] i'm not gonna spend any
time doing this um this is a waste of my
time that's not hurting epictetus he
doesn't care
right and he wouldn't have cared in his
class he's not gonna let himself get
worked up about that
and then if the student you know
realizes later on that it could be
useful for them and they come back to
class he said okay now we can get down
to work and start start uh studying
okay so i i will answer dl's question
there's a little bit of uh back and
forth in the chat thing about that what
do i think about stephen hawking saying
that philosophy is dead i don't think
stephen hawking actually knows enough
about philosophy to make any
pronouncements about that
based on my reading of his works
um but you know
people have been saying that sort of
thing for
uh generation after generation after
generation and it's not
you know so so don't believe you know
just some big name
weighing in about you know philosophy as
such
um
philosophy is going to be around as long
as human beings are around and and we
remain at a certain level of culture
it's going to take different forms
a lot of it's going to be very boring
and you know we we can not read that
stuff right a lot of it's going to be
extremely useful
and then there's going to be a lot of
stuff in in the middle
um and uh but if we actually want to be
able to understand philosophy we have to
spend the time to to read them uh we
have to we have to work through it you
know you don't get to weigh in about
plato if you haven't spent some time
reading plato and thinking about
play-doh because that's sort of like
telling people that you don't like lemon
meringue pie when you've never actually
even had a pie
so i'm a big i'm a big booster of
spending time with the text that said i
think that it's we can't just like throw
text at people and say go to it buddy we
have to provide um some help and some
resources and that's what i try to do in
my my channel
and in my classes
okay let me
scroll back up a lot of new questions
so
here we go
katarina asks should we take practical
advice from stoicism or from any
philosophy there are also different even
contradictory so how do we act without
being too stupid or stubborn
well um
they're not all that contradictory um if
you read through classical moral
philosophy you're not going to find a
lot of people saying that lying is a
good thing
in general
you will find some saying that maybe you
should lie in these circumstances but
not in these
but there's a recognition that in
general truth is better than lying and
now that how do we parse it up or you
know um
should we work on ourselves and change
ourselves or not
i mean plato aristotle the stoics
epicurus they all say yes
um so they're they're not so
contradictory uh it's not like they're
contradictory in every single point and
you know epictetus
uh sort of frames the stoic life as a
process of working through our our
contradictions
we're kind of a mess as human beings
um
now there's a there's a good question
well how do we how do we know which one
we should pick
and i would say
[Music]
it's something that you can experiment
with
right i mean if this is why we do stoic
week it was originally called live as a
stoic
and the idea was you know you give
people some really rudimentary stuff and
some exercises and try to have them be
mindful about what's going on in the day
in terms of their reasoning processes
their emotions their actions
have them do some you know uh you know
sum up of that later on
and provide a community where they can
they can you know talk with each other
and see what happens afterwards
um a lot of people i think can try it
out and they're like yeah it didn't work
for me um and then it could be because
they didn't actually
really apply themselves or they didn't
understand it or it could it really
didn't work for them right
um other people try it out and they're
like yeah this this is
pretty good i guess they're on to
something let me study some more stuff
now i'm going to read marcus aurelius or
i'm going to read epictetus right
and there's there's kind of a a back and
forth process
you can be eclectic
in in how you do this cicero was an
eclectic and he's a great philosopher
i'm an eclectic you know there's some
things that i like in stoicism there's
other things where i'm like i think
aristotle had it more right or i think
you know this is better or that's better
um
and one of the other things to keep in
mind is you you can't possibly read
everybody so you know you find a couple
that seem
initially plausible to you
and then you know try them out see see
what works see if it makes any sense to
you
and that again to go back to that
pragmatic question that's being
pragmatic
um
you know
you have to actually see
whether there's there's anything to it
through experiment
now let me scroll down
um
oh here's a really interesting one
from
chiang chang when
how would you consider hegel's view of
stoicism in comparison with actual stoic
philosophy so this is something i've
written a bit about in the half hour
hegel blog and i actually owe another
entry on it
some of you may know that
one of the big projects i've been
working on for about three and a half
years
and we're actually celebrating a big
milestone about this tomorrow uh we're
having a
online party
um is the half hour hegel project where
i'm taking hegel's
phenomenology of spirit and i'm going
through it line by line paragraph by
paragraph not not skipping anything
commenting on it creating a digital
video commentary that people then can
use for understanding the text you know
we've had
like uh like three or four million
minutes of
those videos viewed uh so a lot of
people found them useful
um
and there is actually a section in the
phenomenology called you know stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy consciousness
so my take on on hegel and stoicism is
he had a very prevalent 19th century
view
on both stoicism and skepticism and
epicureanism that these are hellenistic
philosophy and they're what happens
after the greek city state goes into
decline and they don't really
engage in the kind of great thinking
that plato and aristotle were doing um
and they're really more about the
individual trying to figure out how
they're going to adapt themselves to a
really screwed up and more and more
screwed up uh moral universe that that
they were in
um
[Music]
so i think that
you know
so to begin with that's not an accurate
depiction of stoicism
the other thing is hegel does a bit of
shoe horning i would say to make uh
make things fit
uh the narrative that he he wants to
tell but i love hegel but but sometimes
uh he's he's uh
one-sided to use one of his own words in
doing that
um
let's go on
um
oh
interesting practical question uh
from
uh
artis ar
artisic genus
um
who's actually alfonzo somebody who i
know what do you think marcus aurelius
would say about a leader being obligated
to lie on behalf of a government with
the intention of being positive
for the greater constituency
so like if we get bad news should the
leader maintain an upbeat
cheerful
party line about it or should he tell
people how it is um
well
i think marcus would say that you should
tell people how it is
um
this is a question
the issue of lying
uh or or even holding back on part of
the truth this is a question that did
come up
among the ancient stoics not in terms of
statecraft but in terms of commerce
cicero talks about it in either book
three or book four of on duties and
there was a um
[Music]
a disagreement between two of the great
stoic school arcs
about it diogenes
uh
was more fast and loose with with uh
deception
and i think it's antiochus comes after
him
was much more strict about it
[Music]
so
you know
in general it's going to be better to to
to
tell people how things are because then
they can actually prepare for them
um now you know that that said that
doesn't mean that you would have to
necessarily blurt it from the rooftops
or something like that right
um
so there's there's ways in which you
could you could you could do
that um
oh here's an interesting personal
question
from aokiama you gregory are a
professional philosopher
but are you in any manner active in
politics if not then why not
um
i would say that i am
if i had to like you know say one way or
the other i'd say i'm fairly inactive in
politics you know i don't run for office
i uh i don't uh do a lot of political
posting
um
and um every once in a while i've done
some volunteer work here and there
but i don't i don't do a lot of it but
much of that is because i given the kind
of work load that i have i don't i don't
have a lot of time for that and also
living a a life with my family
i do
find it very difficult to
to locate a home in contemporary
american politics
there's good reasons why
none of the political parties out there
particularly appeal to me i think it's
it's horrible
how the democrats and republicans
uh have become our only options and have
engaged in all this you know crazy
gerrymandering
and rigging the system so that um it's
almost impossible for for third parties
to break in
um i hate the fact that the media is
pretty much uh obsessed with with
those two parties and what's going on
with them and that we have this massive
lobbying machine
uh in large part not caring particularly
about either party unless they're like
you know the nra lobbying the
republicans or nero
lobbying the
democrats um i hate that it's it's it's
sort of the default for most people and
so i find it difficult to to do that
i i
i vote you know i i
do pay close attention to local politics
because that's where we have some
sway
um
but yeah there's there's uh i'm not
particularly optimistic about our
current system
i do think a lot about geopolitics and
sort of the larger picture but i am not
a player at all in that
so
um
[Music]
oh an ordered hole this is an
interesting point it looks like we're
almo we're at time but i'm going to go
over just a little bit
a lot of stoics are readable does that
reflect how far into concepts they go
into
so like the idea i suppose would be the
more readable you are the less deep
you're going into concepts
and i i would say you know that's
there's a contingent relation between
that sometimes you have thinkers who are
very readable and they're also going
very deep into things that's kind of
rare
there's also popularizations that of
course are only going you know very very
uh
you know they're going very shallowly
into things and then we have some people
who are
very deep but hard to understand like
hegel you know or kant for that matter
and there are other people who are
you know the opposite
um
i think that there's there's there's a
lot of philosophical depth to the stoics
much more i would say i've realized now
than than i thought there was when i was
a graduate student
[Music]
and
you know the readability thing
some of that depends on which
translation you get to i mean some of
the older translations are kind of tough
for for quite a few people
um
you know it's interesting donald
robertson was talking about this a while
back
there's you know stoicism provides a
kind of interesting basis in part and
also a great complement to cbt and rebt
approaches cognitive approaches in in
psychotherapy
and yet
people don't usually pick up
a psychotherapeutic work and just read
it and read it and read it over and over
again but they do go back to reading
epictetus and they do go back to reading
marcus
there's something there there's there's
something more there's a surplus there
that draws people back that that you're
not getting just from a handbook
in in rebt or cbt or something along
those lines
um
and i think it's great that it's
readable because the more time people do
spend reading it the more they can get
into the concepts because you know with
philosophy
oftentimes you don't get everything the
20th read in
so that's that's kind of a good good
thing so there's a lot of other
questions
i don't know that i'll get to all of
them
let me
grab a few that that look like they
would be
easy
to
respond to
um
[Music]
so here's here's one
pyrite tool menu how does stoicism
respond to things like non-essentialism
towards human nature and do you think
that difference on these grounds would
be irrelevant to whether one should
actually practice stoicism
so
if you want to say that there isn't a
human nature that's a position that one
shouldn't take for granted any more than
one says that there is a human nature
right
um so the mere fact that there are
alternative points of view doesn't mean
that stoicism then suddenly becomes
wrong you know or is called into the
balance you know um
so you know can you could you practice
stoicism without worrying about whether
there is a human nature yeah you
probably could
um
i think
thinking that there is a common human
nature is is part of the conceptual
apparatus
the other thing i'll say about this too
is you know just to say that there is a
human nature doesn't mean that that
human nature is something simple and i
think a lot of people who want to attack
the notion of human nature
same thing that comes up in the free
will stuff you know generally what
they're going to call human nature or
free will is not what the great thinkers
have meant by it
and so you don't get any mileage out of
just saying well this is wrong and we
know it because of neuroscience or
something like that right
um
you know you gotta actually whenever
you're engaging a philosophical um
position you've got to engage it sort of
at it's at its strongest points
and i just don't see a lot of the you
know non-essentialism discourses out
there um
really doing that
so
um
me scroll down
um
ah so here's here's a question uh and i
think this has been one that this guy
has asked before if it's the same person
i'm thinking about
raudan ibarra will we get a quick course
on marcus aurelius meditations before
march 2018
i would love to understand this text
better it's been my favorite for several
years
i would love to be able to say yes i am
going to be working on on a marcus
course
donald robertson actually has a marcus
course right now um
but i don't think he and i would be
doing exactly the same thing and i do
these very close readings and going you
know into all the different concepts and
stuff like that
um
i think he's much more about immediate
practice practicability although he's
really doing some interesting stuff on
the na you know marcus and his mindset
and what's going on with the history um
right now i i you know i just took on
these two courses at marquette that i
got hired to teach a week before they
started so that has
substantially cut into my time um but
i'm hoping to get to it i i have a few
other things lined up before that i want
to finish this aerosol categories course
and bring that out i want to get a
course on cicero's stoic paradoxes out
but but aurelius is
meditations it's definitely something i
want to do
um
so there's there's a few other ones
um
let me see here i'll take let me see if
i get there's something i can take this
very quickly
uh they're very quick to talk about
um okay so how kamma has has one
that i can answer fairly
easily and then sign off what do you
think are the best and most useful stoic
ideas about human finitude
and
death um
so
interestingly um i was recently on death
uh hangout
talking about this
um with with those guys who do some
really cool work
um
and uh
you know what what does stoicism have to
tell us about death so
death is not something
that um it makes sense for us to to fear
um the idea is that you know
in general we shouldn't try to kill
ourselves or leave the life you know
there is there is a stoic position on
suicide but
stoics also thought that most of the
people who who do commit suicide are
doing so for the wrong reasons
um
but you know we will all die
and so we have to think about our own
death and we also have to think about
the death of others
epictetus for example says something
that
strikes many people as very cold and
saying you know
when you kiss your wife or your child
remind yourself that they are they are
something mortal and and that they they
can die
um and we can say oh
that sucks you know why should i think
those morbid thoughts well by doing so
it frees us up
for
um
appreciating the present that we we can
um do something in where we where we
have some freedom and have some choice
to do something
um the other thing that the stoics also
you know you see them doing is um
they're willing even though they don't
think that the the soul is going to
survive in any meaningful way after
death
they're willing
uh sometimes to
to you know resist tyrants and um to
take a stand for for justice or to
engage in you know like cato did civil
war
um because they think it's the right
thing to do and to to take the chance of
of dying or even sometimes the certainty
of dying as as a result
and so i think they they see it as
the opportunity to die for something and
it doesn't necessarily have to be quite
so
so um
[Music]
dramatic is that you know if we think
about how we devote our our time while
we're alive how we
how we devote our life
um we only have so much time you know we
could die tomorrow
um
or you know i mean i'm i'm 47 so i can
maybe look forward to another 30 or 40
years um you know the
bigger part is is behind me
um
and uh
you know how do i want to use that that
time
um
we have to think in terms of of
priorities and whether it's worth it
spending on
uh these other people
so
the stoics would say yes in general
um
doing our duties and things like that so
so death becomes something that offers
us an opportunity to to um
to think matters through
so i'm going to call this to a close um
and we're already like about 10 minutes
over time
great questions i enjoyed this i'll be
doing another one on facebook live
uh
next week i believe let me actually
check my calendar i believe it's on
wednesday
um but i'm not quite sure yeah it is on
on wednesday
i'll be doing another one
um usually i don't publicize these in
advance because they are pop-ups but
i'll let you guys in on on the secret so
great chat and i will see you some other
time